l'inquiétude grandit en russie toujours
confrontée à une forte circulation d'une
variante delta le pays met l'accent sur
la vaccination pour tenter d'enrayer une
troisième vague épidémique la
correspondance à moscou de faire la
kauffman un moscou la vaccination passe
à la vitesse supérieure le maire de la
capitale sergueï sobianine vient
d'inaugurer un nouveau centre de
vaccination le deuxième en trois jours
cette fois dans le staff sportif
loujniki il est capable d'accueillir
quinze mille personnes par jour selon
s'allier se manie qu'il s'agit d'un des
plus grands vaccinodromes du monde
écoutez la principale arène sportive du
pays a également rejoint la lutte contre
la pandémie contre le coc vide
le nombre de personnes vaccinées à
moscou augmente de jour en jour au cours
de la journée écoulée
cent cinq mille personnes ont reçu une
première ou une deuxième dose du vaccin
c'est un chiffre astronomique et bien
sûr cela nécessite la mise en service de
capacités supplémentaires
l'organisation mondiale de la santé
ayant donné son feu vert à la
vaccination des enfants contre le vide
19 moscou à lancer des essais cliniques
du vaccin foot nick v sur des
adolescents âgés de 12 à 17 ans plus de
20 personnes vient de recevoir leur
première dose du sérum écouter le
processus a débuté hier avec les
premières injections du vaccin
vingt-et-une personnes ont déjà reçu le
premier composant du vaccin dont onze
ont été vaccinées à l'hôpital pour
enfants bacheliers ayéva et 10 à
l'hôpital pour enfants morozov
elles sont sous la surveillance des
médecins seulement deux participants à
l'étude ont une petite fièvre dans
l'ensemble ils se sont tous bien près de
vingt quatre mille nouveaux cas de
coronavirus ont été détectés en russie
ces dernières 24 heures dont plus de
5000 à moscow le nombre des décès est
toujours au plus haut depuis le début de
la pandémie plus de 700 morts quotidiens
sont enregistrées depuis deux jours
consécutifs